when i started comedy 12 years ago i  never considered that what i was saying  was just as important as how  i was saying it how i was saying it how  i was saying it one of my favorite  indian comics rahul subramanian and yes  how i said that was correct he's one of  my favorites because of his ability to  perform his words to life you don't need  to understand hindi to understand in  this clip that he's talking about djs i  hate because every club has this one  dj  and how exactly he feels about them the  moment they open their mouth have you  seen the kind of [ __ ] that they see how  are you doing mumbai  oh are you doing mumbai who the [ __ ]  talks to a city  i just wish i knew this when i started  because